It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Both of you, good morning!
Good morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 128th episode!
BAU BAU BAU!
128 episodes.
That's a lot of episodes!
BAU BAU!
Hi!
Morning!
Wow!
Hi Ruffians!
Maybe today isn't your 128th FUWAMOCO Morning!
Wait, wait, wait.
Maybe it's not yours, but it's ours.
Is there any Ruffians that... It is their 128th episode!
I should've done that.
You!
You're new!
You're so Ruffians!
You, yes!
I'll put down the windows.
What if you're here for the beginning but then you fall back asleep halfway through?
Does that count?
That's a discussion for another time, I think.
We need more science to prove so.
Well, for those that are joining us for the first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCAR!
Hosted by us!
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Or, please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
I was wondering if there's any Ruffians that are doing this for all 128 episodes of FUWAMOCO Morning.
So fun!
Do you say the intro together with us?
That's a good question.
Why?
I think there's a lot of science that needs to be done in this episode, huh?
I think so.
You missed a single episode!
That's okay.
Thank you!
Thank you for always being here to start your days off together with us, Ruffians!
Where's FUWAMOCO morning today without Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
Let's start it off!
Our weekend's just about to start!
It's Friday!
It's gonna be a good day!
Except... We have bad news.
You can ask questions or we can take a look!
Hi!
We have ice cream muffins!
Yeah, some delicious mochi ice cream on one side and... What do we do, Ruffians?
Do we just close our eyes and eat them?
We could!
What do you think, Ruffians?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
I think he's got bones, right?
Can't eat him.
Mochi ice cream with something extra special in the middle.
Maybe the Ruffians don't want to eat Pero.
You can go ahead and I'll have the other one on the other side.
Yeah, we'll skip eating weird stuff.
Yeah, you know, he's probably just gonna taste nasty like garbage.
He might be sort of stretchy like mochi though, huh?
Ruffians that decide to eat him could tell us how he tastes.
Have you been giving him that much pudding, Ruffians?
I don't think so.
Well, it's a doggy dog world out there, huh?
BAU BAU!
Now I want ice cream.
Mochi ice cream.
You give me that?
I can't eat ice cream!
Please stay in the morning!
It's the rules.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
Actually recently, we hit a really exciting milestone!
After all the whole GTA silliness and everything, FUWAMOCO!
We've reached 960,000 Ruffians here on YouTube!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
That's only 40,000 Ruffians away from our big dream of 1 million subscribers here on YouTube!
Wow!
So close!
I can't believe that, you know, we're getting so close to having such a massive day, everybody's come cheering!
Thank you, Ruffians.
Thank you so much for joining us on our journey so far.
As you know, we're sure that we'll be able to do some even more amazing things after we hit our 1 million goal.
So let's continue to have lots of fun and try new things here while we're at it, you know?
Thank you!
Thank you just a little bit!
Mama puppy, when?
We already said 5 million.
That's it!
That's right.
She's like, it was really nice, I had a lot of fun!
She's so happy, she's like, I got to get to see you!
Yeah.
She saw you, yeah.
She saw you, Moco.
Yeah, yeah!
Yeah, Moco will be the five million.
Five million, okay?
Got it!
But once we hit one million, we're not so far away anymore.
No!
We're only one fifth of the way there.
Ruffians, you might think it's sort of silly, this sort of stuff, but things like this are important, okay?
So continue working hard!
To our big dream of 1 million Ruffians here on YouTube!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
BAU BAU!
Wow!
More exciting news!
You know, the very cool original timeline senpai from Promise, Orvokroni, she just released a brand new original song called Soten ni Muyuu!
BAU BAU!
Look at it!
It's so cool!
Kroni-senpai.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
It's a really cool song where you can kind of see here, but Mori-senpai, she's gonna splash her way through things like a samurai through all the danger that comes her way.
Yeah, and it has a really sharp vibe to it.
Like a sword.
Yeah, like a sword.
The lyrics are super cool.
I think they were really tricky, and especially, you know, there's an explosive rap portion to the song, too.
So you really need to go check it out!
Japanese lyrics, too.
Konomi-senpai, she did her best.
Yeah, but you know, it's nice to finally be able to listen to it like this, in case you remember it.
Oh, I remember.
We've been waiting.
Kronii-senpai!
She first revealed her song during Connect the World!
I was so excited!
What's this?
Is this an original song?
Yeah!
But now!
You know her English first concert.
Yeah, Connect the World.
Not Breaking the Magic, Connect the World.
Connect the World!
But now!
Now so ten million years out, we can listen to it!
Yeah, and you know apparently Kronii-senpai's been working on it for a long time.
Since around even debut for her, too.
So, please go take a listen to it, okay?
As you know, it's all her hard work.
It's finally come to fruition.
So please go take a listen.
Ah, congratulations Kuro-nii-senpai!
Congratulations!
BAU BAU!
Officials are so cool too.
It takes a lot to release an original song, okay Ruffians?
BAU BAU!
Wow, we also wanted to share something today, Ruffians!
You know how hard we work at Voice Pack, right?
We have a cool fact to share with you!
FUWAMOCO!
We've participated in every Voice Pack we could on since debut!
That's pretty amazing, right?
Every single one!
Thank you!
You know voice packs, it's a lot of fun but it's a lot of hard work too!
Yeah you know we really enjoy it and we want to get better at it too!
You know we put a lot of effort into it.
And the scripts and everything as well.
Yeah, yeah, the scripts as well.
Yeah, and maybe there's a few Ruffians that haven't listened to a voice buff before.
It can be really confusing.
Sometimes it can be a bit difficult to find them, too.
Oh, yeah.
But you can find them on the official hololive shop!
Yeah!
They're very similar to what, like, a drama CD would be for an anime.
What's a drama CD though?
You know, you have all the characters talking and a special scenario.
Music, sound effects, very immersive.
But it's only something that you can listen to.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Wow.
I think it was kind of popular amongst the Ruffians, I wonder why.
But!
It will actually be ending in sale period at the end of this month, so only a few days left, Ruffians!
May, May soon!
Yeah.
They're not on sale forever, okay?
Not forever, you might think that, but that's not the case.
Yeah, and, well, this was the first voice pack of FUWAMOCO that we did together!
Yeah, and, you know...
That means it's a Tomb Raider voice pack, right?
Yes!
You can't explain what getting married to FUWAMOCO is like in this voice pack!
BAU BAU!
Again and again!
There's some really silly moments at times, so you won't want to miss a Ruffian.
It's a bit silly, huh?
Yeah.
There's another popular one that's brand new!
Dream Love Voice Pack.
They're not all like this!
They're not all like this, this is just the two that happened to be highlighted today.
But this time, you can hear both a very scary yandere, Fuwawa and Mococo.
Ruffians, what kind of things do you think would make Fuwawa and Mococo into yandere?
Apparently, plushie dog.
Please go and find out, take a listen to it, and then you'll be able to see the real demon dog behind FUWAMOCO.
Apparently some wolfies were very terrified, so please take a school day flashback or howl.
I know you don't really get to hear the very very yawning points in the sample, so...
You'll have to check it out at FUWAMOCO!
We'll continue to do our best with our voice packs.
So please cheer us on, Ruffians!
We're so happy that you enjoy them so much!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
I feel like today is for good news, good news, good news!
Yeah!
And we have even more good news!
There was something super happy that happened.
And I think maybe a lot of Ruffians might not have noticed?
Yeah!
But Ruffians, there's a new, very tiny Ruffian amongst us now!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
This Ruffian, Abyssgard!
Congratulations, Sobbi!
Congratulations, BAU BAU!
I'm so happy!
Right? We can't wait to hear his first BAU BAU!
Abbysgard's first BAU BAU. I'm sure it'll be super cute!
Before you know it, you'll be off to a first day of kindergarten!
They grow up really fast, huh?
Yeah, you'll definitely be the coolest kid in class with that name you know.
Fuwawa Abyssgard, Mococo Abyssgard and.. Abyssgard!
But you might not want to mess with him, or there might be EXTREME VIOLENCE!
It's a misunderstanding?
Huh?
What?
Misunderstanding?
What do you mean, Ruffians?
Misunderstanding, misunderstanding...
Little brother!
Congratulations on the brother! Not child.
It's just a joke.
We hope you have tons of fun together with your brother Abyssgard!
You know, definitely teach him how to draw lots and lots of keys!
Yeah, maybe you can dress him up as Pero too.
It would be cute, not nasty.
Maybe just this once.
BAU BAU! Have lots of fun with your brother Abbysgard! BAU BAU!
He will get bigger eventually, right?
They grow fast.
BAU BAU!
You know how much we love to sing right, Ruffians?
And well, it's not just FUWAMOCO that loves to sing, but all of Advent!
And because of that and a bunch of other things, we released another song cover!
Altogether, all five of us, all of Advent!
We released...
Weegloss' first debut original song, Silicone Heart Beat!
You know, all to celebrate the first anniversary.
Weegloss' first anniversary!
Yeah, it's so good!
Please take a listen to it.
It's on the hololive English Official Channel.
And in the cover here, I get to sing Lydian Sky and Moco-chan.
I get Bibika's part!
Yeah, it was so much fun.
It's such a catchy song.
The lyrics are really fun to sing.
Especially the end, it was kind of tricky.
It was very tricky at the end.
Right.
But please go take a look at the lesson over... You can compare them, you know?
This is how Almond does it.
I definitely put my own sort of flair into it.
Right, right.
Me and Mococo.
I'm sure all of Advent was like that.
So please go take a listen.
And, well, it's Weegloss' first anniversary.
But there's a lot going on.
It's not only their first anniversary.
No, a big, big, big, big thing is happening.
Weegloss' 3D debut live is happening tomorrow at 4AM PDT.
FUWAMOCO we really want to be there live to be able to congratulate them.
So we're doing a watch-along together with Biboo on our channel here.
We'll be doing a watch-along.
I know it's very early in the morning for some Ruffians, but we hope that maybe you can check it out along with us and some glossers too!
Yeah, we want to be able to congratulate them all together!
Yeah, and then, you know, this way we'll be able to see Free Gloss's first steps in 3D as a music group too!
Yeah, exciting!
Yeah, 4AM!
BAU BAU!
It's time for the Doggie of the Day!
Let's check out who exactly the Doggie of the Day is.
Today's Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Look!
Oh my gosh, he's so fluffy!
So fluffy with a big nose!
I feel like it has to be a rule that you have to push the nose.
Why?
It's like a button.
Yeah!
Yeah, Bandit looks like a real-life Garibaldi, right?
Yeah, Garibaldi!
Garibaldi, Garibaldi, Garibaldi!
No, this isn't Garibaldi!
It's Bandit!
Yeah!
He just looks alike, huh?
I'm so happy to wake up to that face right in my face!
Yeah, maybe Bandit has a nice spider costume, or maybe that's gonna be Bandit's Halloween costume!
That would be very cute, but I don't think Bandit needs that to be cute.
Bandit's already cute.
BAU BAU!
Who does Bandit BAU BAU?
Moco-chan!
BAU BAU!
Wow wow!
I like that!
It's a little bit younger than I thought.
Younger?
Yeah.
It's very cute though.
Are you saying I'm wrong?
I don't know, it could be like... I don't know about that.
We'll have to disagree, huh?
It's okay.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
I love you.
That's what's going on in Bandit's head!
Because, you know, Bandit is a very distinguished gentleman, you know?
And he's just always thinking about how to make you smile even more!
Thank you, Bandit.
BAU BAU!
And now, we have what today I've read.
I feel like that's the first time I've ever heard it be delivered like that.
Today, I went on a walk.
Finally perfected it, maybe?
May we go.
Let's take a look where Ruffians have been going for walks, huh?
Okay!
De-den!
Komorebi!
Yay!
My favorite Japanese word!
The light's going through the trees.
You see it?
The sort of the...
Sunbeam is there.
Yeah, Komorebeam.
Yeah, it looks like you have such a nice and comfy walk.
Very nice.
I feel like I can smell it.
Right, I can hear it.
Yeah.
Wow, I like this walk that you went on.
It looks a little bit cool too, like it's still sunny, but colder.
Like relaxing, refreshing.
Very good work.
It's a little bit bittersweet, but we're sure that that scenery will be changing colors, changing dramatically very shortly, so... Let's enjoy it while we can!
We're sure you're gonna have to get back out there and see just how it's changed really soon, so... Have fun looking!
Have fun!
FUWAMOCO!
And for our Question of the Day!
We have... De-den!
Good morning FUWAMOCO!
Something I've always paid close attention for is how you both move in 3D.
Especially how you both seem to enjoy making your ears and tails move!
Isn't really fun?
What other aspects of your 3D models do you enjoy the most?
BAU BAU!
A little bit nervous, but I feel like it was really seamless going from my 2D bodies to my 3D bodies first.
You know, we're still getting used to things, doing our best, but we really, you know, we hope that we'll have lots of opportunities to be able to show our 3D souls to you lots and, you know, bounce around here and there!
It's just really fun!
I think everything about it is our favorite, so... Did you look forward to that, Ruffians?
FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
Thank you Ruffians!
Thank you so much for all your submissions!
Do you have a question for us?
I bet you have a question for us.
Please let us know your questions with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
Also if you happen to see Pero, please let us know.
You know, it's kinda nasty.
It's serious.
It's important to let all the Ruffians know where he has been.
Also your walks, you know, now it's really getting much cooler outside so it's a good time of year to take a walk.
Yeah!
Very relaxing!
And if you happen to see a fluffy or fuzzy dog, please let us know!
It might become the Doggie of the Day!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
And next, we have another stream coming up.
Very soon!
We have De-den!
Team Fortress 2!
We're gonna be playing Team Fortress 2 for the very first time with a bunch of our hololive members!
Oh, maybe.
Ice cream.
Yeah, Ami-senpai is having a very special Valve Game Manathon day today.
So we're gonna be playing a part, being a part, playing together with everybody, a part of the celebration.
Ami, are we construction workers with guns?
I don't know.
Mayo?
Mayo-man?
I don't know.
I don't know what to expect.
I think there's guns involved though.
I would think that there's guns involved but maybe hard hats.
I don't know.
I think we're gonna be part of a team.
Defending a fortress.
For the second time!
We'll do our best and have a bunch of fun together with everybody and Ame-senpai!
BAU BAU!
And our schedule!
Well, not just Team Fortress 2.
Later on!
At around 7pm PT, we'll be playing Gary's Mod over on Abyss Senpai's channel!
So make sure you don't forget.
Don't forget.
Oh, Team Fortress 2 is done.
Oh, that's everything.
Cuz that is not everything, not at all.
Abyss Senpai has a bunch more games going over on her channel.
Yes, it is a marathon.
And then we'll be back for Gary's Mod, so please join everybody in a really fun celebration.
And then it's not on the schedule, but after that, we have our
We glossed 3D life much along.
But that's obviously very very early in the morning so please make sure you put your sleep first, okay my friends?
Because, after that, we're gonna be having a Rock n' Rawr Party!
So it, so it, officially comes to an end when we finish the last song, the encore.
Maybe we deserve an encore.
I'm not a chihuahua, but maybe if we do so, we touch your heart.
And if we have a lot of fun that you think we deserve an encore, then I'd be really happy to be able to end summer with an encore, but I don't know.
So we're gonna sing a lot of songs and have a lot of fun, so please join us, Ruffians!
I'm so excited.
It's been a little while since the last Welcome Board Party.
It's been a lot going on.
So, let's end the summer with a big, big BAU Showcase!
BAU BAU!
Well, now we have a whole new day, so we're gonna do our best that day.
But!
For Ruffians joining us in the archive today, here is your FUWAMOCO-ed win!
It's BAU BAU BB Ruffian!
BAU BAU!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
No!
It's okay!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Another FUWAMOCO Morning is not starting yet.
It will be starting on Monday.
Monday!
Yeah, don't get confused.
It's ending.
Yeah.
But thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Chihuahuan!
BAU BAU!
Cat!
This way!
BAU BAU!
Cartoon Bowser!
Brand new Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Dark Eater.
SK.
BAU BAU!
Destiny.
Kanda Kai.
BAU BAU!
FUNTIME.
Boyo.
BAU BAU!
Kaminari.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!